BUT JOE, THAT'S WHAT THE PEOPLE
SEEM TO WANT, AND I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO LIZ CHENEY.
LET'S STEP IN.
>> FRIENDS AND FAMILY,
ESPECIALLY WONDERFUL TO BE HERE
ON THE BEAUTIFUL RANCH, AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH, BRAD AND
KATE, FOR THAT WONDERFUL
INTRODUCTION.
WE REALLY ARE IN GOD'S COUNTRY.
AND IT'S WONDERFUL TO WELCOME SO
MANY HERE.
I WANT TO SAY FIRST OF ALL, A
SPECIAL THANKS TO EVERY MEMBER
OF TEAM CHENEY WHO IS HERE IN
THE AUDIENCE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND TO TELL YOU OUR WORK IS FAR
FROM OVER.
[APPLAUSE]
AMONG THE MANY, MANY BLESSINGS
THAT WE HAVE AS AMERICANS AND AS
INDIVIDUALS AND AS HUMAN BEINGS,
THE BLESSING OF FAMILY IS SURELY
THE MOST IMPORTANT, AND SO I
WANT TO THANK ALL MY FAMILY AND
PAY SPECIAL TRIBUTE TO THOSE WHO
ARE HERE WITH US TONIGHT.
MY MOM AND DAD, DICK CHENEY AND
LIZ CHENEY.
[APPLAUSE]
AND MY HUSBAND PHIL.
[LAUGHS]
AND FOUR OF OUR FIVE KIDS ARE
HERE.
KATIE AND GRACIE AND PHILIP AND
RICHARD ARE ALL HERE TONIGHT.
[APPLAUSE]
AND ELIZABETH IS STARTING LAW
SCHOOL TODAY, SO WE WILL HAVE
ANOTHER GENERATION CARRYING ON
DEDICATION TO THE CONSTITUTION
AND TO OUR FREEDOM.
[APPLAUSE]
A LITTLE OVER A YEAR AGO I
RECEIVED A NOTE FROM A GOLD STAR
FATHER.
HE SAID TO ME STANDING UP FOR
TRUTH HONORS ALL WHO GAVE ALL.
AND I HAVE THOUGHT OF HIS WORDS
EVERY SINGLE DAY SINCE THEN.
I'VE THOUGHT OF THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE A REMINDER OF HOW WE
MUST ALL CONDUCT OURSELVES.
WE MUST CONDUCT OURSELVES IN A
WAY THAT IS WORTHY OF THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO WEAR THE UNIFORM
OF THIS NATION, AND IN
PARTICULAR OF THOSE WHO HAVE
GIVEN THE ULTIMATE SACRIFICE.
[APPLAUSE]
THIS IS NOT A GAME.
EVERY ONE OF US MUST BE
COMMITTED TO THE ETERNAL DEFENSE
OF THIS MIRACULOUS EXPERIMENT
CALLED AMERICA.
END OF THE HEART OF OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS OUR
ELECTIONS.
THEY ARE THE FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLE OF OUR CONSTITUTION.
TWO YEARS AGO I WON THIS PRIMARY
WITH 73% OF THE VOTE.
I COULD EASILY HAVE DONE THE
SAME AGAIN.
THE PATH WAS CLEAR.
BUT IT WOULD HAVE REQUIRED THAT
I GO ALONG WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LIE ABOUT THE
2020 ELECTION.
IT WOULD HAVE REQUIRED THAT I
ENABLE HIS ONGOING EFFORTS TO
UNRAVEL OUR DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM
AND ATTACK THE FOUNDATIONS OF
OUR REPUBLIC.
THAT WAS A PATH I COULD NOT AND
WOULD NOT TAKE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
KNOW HOW SEAT, NO OFFICE IN THIS
LAND IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE
PRINCIPLES THAT WE ARE ALL SWORN
TO PROTECT.
AND I WELL UNDERSTOOD THE
POTENTIAL POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES
OF ABIDING BY MY DUTY.
OUR REPUBLIC RELIES UPON THE
GOODWILL OF ALL CANDIDATES FOR
OFFICE TO ACCEPT HONORABLY THE
OUTCOME OF ELECTIONS, AND
TONIGHT, HARRY HEIDEMAN HAS
RECEIVED THE MOST VOTES IN THIS
PRIMARY.
SHE WON.
I CALLED HER TO CONCEDE THE
RACE.
THIS PRIMARY ELECTION IS OVER.
BUT NOW THE REAL WORK BEGINS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THE GREAT AND ORIGINAL CHAMPION
OF OUR PARTY, ABRAHAM LINCOLN,
WAS DEFEATED IN ELECTIONS FOR
THE SENATE AND THE HOUSE BEFORE
HE WON THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELECTION OF ALL.
LINCOLN ULTIMATELY PREVAILED, HE
SAVED OUR UNION, AND HE DEFINED
OUR OBLIGATION AS AMERICANS FOR
ALL OF HISTORY.
SPEAKING AT GETTYSBURG OF THE
GREAT TASK REMAINING BEFORE US,
LINCOLN SAID THAT WE HEAR HIGHLY
RESOLVE THAT THESE DEAD SHALL
NOT HAVE DIED IN VAIN, THAT THIS
NATION UNDER GOD SHALL HAVE A
NEW BIRTH OF FREEDOM AND THAT
GOVERNMENT OF THE PEOPLE, BY THE
PEOPLE, AND FOR THE PEOPLE SHALL
NOT PERISH FROM THIS EARTH.
AS WE MEET HERE TONIGHT, THAT
REMAINS OUR GREATEST AND MOST
IMPORTANT TASK.
MOST OF WORLD HISTORY IS A STORY
OF VIOLENT CONFLICT, SERVITUDE
AND SUFFERING.
MOST PEOPLE IN MOST PLACES HAVE
NOT LIVED IN FREEDOM.
OUR AMERICAN FREEDOM IS A
PROVIDENTIAL DEPARTURE FROM
HISTORY.
WE ARE THE EXCEPTION.
WE HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE GIFT OF
FREEDOM BY GOD AND OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS.
IT HAS